no you have an anniversary coming up the
right is it three years yeah your wife
yeah that's right because we are in the
industry but we're of different cloths
in the industry the keys and manager I'm
in you know artist so it's different so
how to artists enjoy sure I mean we're
we're cut from two different clubs as
well she's brilliant and and and I and
and and I and I am her husband I'm the
guy who screws up Aaron Sorkin dialogue
no yeah we do we have our anniversary
coming up and it is it's a tricky thing
you know and like negotiating
relationships inside the industry and
all that sort of stuff but but it's
mostly just has to do with like
parenting and who's going to be around
and what you're gonna do and how close
do you want you know your kids to be to
this industry and all of that sort of
because you wanted to be a part of what
you're doing you won them around but
then you're like this isn't normal and
you're kind of being weird about it we
both are like super working-class kids
like yeah you know what I mean like we
grew up I grew up in a small town in
Texas and she grew up in Pennsylvania
and like we don't want this thing ever
it's what we do it's not who we are
yeah like that's not exactly what we
want to like take to coming from
small-town Texas girls well it's nice
that they are minute and it's not all
the cuz they're rounded all the time is
she so she's gonna be so bored of it
yeah she's three right she's Oh cuz I
have a three oldest that's one of ours
is three yeah I call it three n'ajjer
yes yeah she has white a lot of opinions
she is not afraid of expressing them
that's kind of a bold girl Elijah she's
tough
yeah she's tough as nails you want her
to be like that oh I do yeah I totally
do and she's gonna grind me down
I'm like I am a broken man literally
mine do the same thing I look at my
husband why are they so mean I just want
to make you happy I know and I know that
being really like why do you guys have
to go to work I'm like do you like your
house do like your Barbie no it's like
yeah but not as much as I like my mom
and then you bear that's not fair though
because my mom was a single mom and
wasn't able to be around a lot and I'm
great
[Applause]
it's definitely one of those things
where you got to put them in their place
about that stuff yeah I mean but I don't
care with me as mom gets to do with you
[Laughter]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this